-You know, this is very
exciting.
There's so much exciting
to talk about.
But this is your ninth time
on the show.
You have moved into a tie
for first place.
-What?
-With your arch-nemesis,
Martha Stewart.
[ Laughter ]
-For first place in terms of --
-Guests on the show.
-Most times being
on Seth's show?
-Yeah.
-Me and Martha Stewart?
-Nine times each.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-She was a full guest or some
of them were cooking?
-Some of them were cooking.
-Ahh, then I win.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah, that's true.
That's fully true.
-That's a segment.
It was so exciting.
I was watching the Emmys
and you won the Emmy
for this wonderful special
that I was lucky enough
to see at Radio City.
-Thank you. That was --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How was that night?
-It was -- I was totally,
totally surprised.
It was amazing and extremely
flattering.
But I was just shocked to win.
And I -- you know,
have been before,
and sometimes it's not fun.
So I was sitting there, like,
"Why do we do this every year?
Why do we come to this?"
And then they said my name
and I was like, "Ahh!"
[ Laughter ]
"This is true love."
-I was very happy
because it cut to you
and Dan Levy,
who is a dear friend of yours,
was your
date for the night.
-World's funniest comedian
Dan Levy
was my date for the night, yes.
-And I'm lucky enough to
know him as well,
and it was really
a genuine moment of friendship
from Dan when you won.
And there he is next to you.
-Oh, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-There was also our friend,
Michelle Wolf,
who's genuinely happy
for you.
-Yeah, Michelle Wolf, yes.
Look at Dan and I.
That is, like -- that is
the typical, like,
Catholic and Jew
hearing good news.
[ Laughter ]
He's like, "Wow!"
And I'm like, "Okay,
don't get too proud."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-You --
A moment
that probably helped you
not get too proud is Deadline,
which is a website
that sort of does a --
-It's a website.
-Yeah, it's a website.
-Yeah.
-They do -- it's breaking news
throughout the Emmys.
They post who wins.
-They pride themselves
on knowing the most
about Hollywood, yeah.
-Yeah. And so they put up
that you won
and they misspelled your name.
Now I will admit,
when I first met you,
I had an issue with Mulaney,
'cause I sometimes accidentally
would put two Ls.
And then I learned pretty
quickly into our friendship
it's one L.
-One L.
-But that was not even
the issue with them.
-No.
-They screwed up on John.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"Juophn."
-[ Laughs ]
-Ask your doctor about
taking Juophn.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, wow.
What -- what...
-Yeah.
-...happened there?
-The other "what happened?"
moment at the Emmys was,
right after you won,
the winner
for Best Director
of a Variety Special
proposed to his wife,
which was sort of this
indelible moment at the Emmys.
-Yeah.
-How was that for you?
-Well, I was backstage
and I was in the glow of --
of being a hypocrite
and now loving awards.
And then everyone
started going, like, "Ah!"
And I was like,
"Yes, indeed, it's me."
And they said this guy proposed.
And that's great for them.
I wish them a long and happy
marriage.
Uh, it really stepped on
my moment.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, you only get
so many.
They'll be married forever.
I'm only going to be there
holding a trophy
for a couple hours.
But you know,
that's la vie Juophn Mulaney.
[ Laughter ]
They got Mulaney right.
-They nailed Mulaney.
They got every part of it right.
Juophn.
-Yeah. Juophn.
-And you definitely look
like a John.
If there were two people there,
they were like,
"Is it John or Juophn?"
You feel like somebody
would be like, "It's John."
-Step aside.
-"It's definitely John."
-People will get Mulaney
wrong sometimes,
like add two Ls
or Mulvaney,
which is, I guess, a name.
-Mm-hmm.
-Which sounds ridiculous to me.
-Mulvaney?
-Yeah, my name is Mulaney.
And to me, Mulvaney, it's like,
"That's not a name."
-Right.
-That sounds like if I, like,
had a throbbing vein,
the "New York Post"
would be like, "Mulvaney,"
like -- but...
[ Laughter ]
To me that's not a regular name.
And yet people around
this great nation walk around
with the name Mulvaney.
-[ Laughs ]
They have your
"New York Post" headline name.
-Yeah, they have a goofy name
with a wrong letter.
-That's no life.
That's no kind of life.
-That's no life. Yeah.